what are polite numbers a polite number  is a positive integer that can be  written as the sum of two or more  consecutive positive integers for  instance 12 is a polite number 10 and 21  are polite numbers too what are impolite  numbers then yes a positive integer  which cannot be written as a sum of  consecutive integers is called an  impolite number but here's a question  for you given a number how do you know  if it's polite or impolite you may take  a while to answer this let me help you  here the impolite numbers are exactly  the powers of two and the polite numbers  are the natural numbers that are not  powers of two so 2 4 8 16 and so on are  impolite and the other natural numbers  are polite read the first comment for  some trivia